because of how painful it was it's a
huge deal
it's not a trivial experience to go
through
my name is quail and i'm one of the
midwives calling from b-pass was the
worst pain i've ever been in
in my life it really encourages this
idea of abortion happening in secret
you're somewhere on your own private
well you're not going to be interrupted
in any country any society that doesn't
provide
easy access to abortion the problem
doesn't go away it goes underground
as a result of that when it goes
underground girls and women die
so this is the main entrance and when
you come in you'll be
greeted asked to clean your hands and
we'll take your temperature as well
before the pandemic you'd come somewhere
like this
if you needed an abortion in here is one
of our early medical rooms so if you
require a scan
or if you require your iron level to be
tested
this is one of the rooms that you'll be
coming into to see the clinician
but now that's changed i had
hot water bottles painkillers um
cups of tea when the pain got too much i
went upstairs
the stomach cramps were honestly so
painful
that it was just so nice to be in the
comfort of my own home
megan is one of an estimated hundred
thousand women
the first group in uk history to legally
have
abortions at home the law changed
temporarily
in march 2020 with lockdown and the
change
could be set to stay it was basically
like taking any other medication
where you can see the risks and side
effects um
but with loads of extra hotlines and
checklists just to make sure everything
was safe
and at home abortion is not as it might
sound the vast majority of terminations
happen
in early pregnancy so before 10 weeks
which means no surgery
is required so when lockdown hit telly
medical service was set up which meant
that consultations could happen remotely
and pills were posted to women in need
and these are the pills that arrive
through the letterbox
this is myforpristone which previously
had to be taken at a clinic
it ends the life of a fetus and
misoprostol
which is taken 24 to 48 hours later
which
expels the pregnancy by april 2020
a third of all abortions were now
happening at home
just two months later this had jumped to
more than half
the subject of abortion just isn't
talked about very much perhaps
because it forces us to confront
difficult issues around
morality and ethics but i think it
should be talked about
we know that abortions are happening
more and more
so i want to find out if our abortion
laws are fit for purpose
and crucially if the pandemic might just
have triggered a revolution
in abortion access here in the uk
the royal college of obstetricians and
gynecologists
has been calling for at-home abortions
for years
if i was organizing your early abortion
care
i would have to ask you to take the
tablets
in the clinic and then you might start
bleeding or having cramp and pain and
much discomfort and embarrassment
on your journey home this means that
women don't have to travel
don't have to be subjected to long waits
and delays in order to
obtain the abortion i'm hiring up the
bed this is just for my back
we know that for every week that a
pregnancy increases in gestation
uh the risks go up i work
in an area that has quite a large south
asian population
a lot of young women are not supposed to
necessarily be sexually
active if they do get pregnant out of a
wedlock that can
be you know a threat to their home
situation
so there's some cold gel coming so
especially with covid where there's less
excuse for people to sometimes be going
outside of the home
um really really challenging to justify
um you know taking taking hours to go
somewhere women travel from all over the
uk
to this abortion clinic in east london
can i ask you to confirm your safe word
for me please your security word
but they now provide telemedical
abortions to 15 to 20 women a week
great thank you very much i mean there's
very few positives to come from the last
year but i will say that the home use of
miffy pristone is
top of my list it is meant that it's
normalized
and abortion care for women basic
reproductive health care
the law change has meant 80 percent of
abortions took place before eight weeks
gestation in 2020
compared with 60 percent in 2019
only 0.95 percent of women will suffer
major complications
but five percent of women who have at
home abortions will suffer complications
that may need follow-up treatment or
surgery
that's been around 96 women every week
or 14 women per day women like
sophie she asked us to change her name
so she could remain anonymous
i'm a nurse and i know him a little bit
about what's normal
and it was not normal there was so much
blood coming
sophie visited an abortion clinic in
july 2020
and was allowed to take her abortion
pills at home
i started to get really intense cramping
and it was the worst pain i've ever been
in in my life
i couldn't move from the floor my friend
who is also a nurse was checking on me
i begged her to give me more cocodemol
and ibuprofen
and then the next morning the bleeding
started
the bleeding was really heavy for about
three
three or four weeks i would say
eventually
sophie needed surgery one of the most
horrific things i think that happened
that i wasn't expecting at five weeks
and two days
was the stuff that was coming out of me
and i'm sorry for being a bit graphic
but
i do think it's our right actually as
women to understand what can happen
and to have all the information before
you make this sort of choice
they say you pass blood clots i would
say there were there were pieces of i
guess
i don't know if it was placenta
more and more women want to have access
to abortions
in 2019 there were 207
384 in england and wales the highest
number
since records began
[Music]
abortion rights have been a hard one
it's still actually illegal
although the abortion act in 1967 gave
women
in england wales and scotland legal
defenses
to end a pregnancy
northern ireland joined them in 2019.
wendy savage was one of the first women
to qualify as a consultant in obstetrics
and gynecology
at the london hospital of course
i'm the last generation of doctors who
qualified who saw women
dying of abortion in this country our
politicians
don't recognize that if a woman doesn't
want to continue with a pregnancy she
will do anything to get rid of it
even if that means she loses her life
believe it or not this house on a quiet
residential street in north london is
actually the site of the first ever
family planning clinic
here in the uk it was opened by mary
stopes 100 years ago
of course a lot has happened since then
and it's interesting to think that if
the law does change many women may
choose never to step foot in the clinic
when accessing an abortion and for some
that is controversial
[Music]
emily's attended prayer vigils outside
abortion clinics
and is now opposed to abortions at home
i don't think there's very much
dignified
about on abortion alone um in lockdown
and i don't think that you know we
do women any kind of favor
when you know we encourage this kind of
thing to happen behind closed doors i
think actually
the whole telemedicine abortion it
really encourages this idea of abortion
happening in secret
christian concern tried to legally
challenge at home abortions but the
court of appeal dismissed their case
now they've gone to the supreme court
with their appeal
do you think it trivializes abortion do
you think it risks
making abortion a form of contraception
here somehow as a society we've got to a
place whereby
we can send a couple of pills through
the post
to women that we haven't medically
assessed clinically assessed
we think that we can send the pills by
post not not seeing them
we think we can send them some
painkillers um
some really strong painkillers and that
it's okay
giving these pills like they're not like
it's nothing
it's not nothing it's huge
i think that's absolutely crazy that you
can't get contraception in the post but
you can get this pill
because this pill is really invasive
this is not like contraception
we mustn't trivialize this issue
it's life-changing
for the mother she will live with this
decision for the rest of her life
and of course it's life-changing for the
the
unborn child that never gets to see life
while abortion is not a zero-sum choice
it's costly dr kate griezly's written
two books on the ethics of abortion
and is dismissive of such arguments
at the very very least it's quite an
inconvenience but there are lots of
other things
beyond that it can be very painful
it requires recovery time always it can
be emotionally difficult
not necessarily but it can be
i think so to imagine that women will
use this
as just a form of contraception
to me suggests a limited comprehension
of what abortion is actually like
because of how painful it was it's a
huge deal it's not a trivial experience
to go through
and i think just because um
the pills by post service makes abortion
more accessible
i don't think it means that it's easy to
terminate a pregnancy
thank you for calling mary stokes
international christian concern
commissioned a mystery client survey
which tests the ethical provision of
medical products
and it did raise safeguarding concerns
we've got here that the first date of
your last period was the 18th of may
yeah that's right and you're pretty sure
of that date yeah i'm sure
you know there have been you know
well-documented cases currently that are
you know women have been able to access
these pills well beyond the 10-week
limit
and that there aren't any checks so
actually it's about safeguarding not
just safety
of the procedure the royal college of
obstetricians and gynecologists says
this happens in 0.004 percent of cases
and it hasn't resulted in any further
complications in a statement msi
reproductive choices said
we know we can trust women to make
decisions about what is best for their
individual health care needs
the 10-week limit is a regulatory limit
in england but it's arbitrary
and not based on safety or evidence
for some people telemedicine won't work
because of
maybe language issues because of
coercive control
it actually might be easier if they say
they're popping out to the shops
because their phone lines are monitored
for young people who don't necessarily
have
access to their own phone so telling
medicine cures
or helps a lot of
problems and barriers but it's not going
to be
um a solution um for everybody
one important consequence of the
temporary change in the law
has been the disappearance of illegal
abortion pills via the internet
the demand from women in england and
scotland and wales has just dropped away
just doesn't exist anymore for wendy
savage
a pro-choice trailblazer it's a reminder
of the risks women will take to end
an unwanted pregnancy i suppose the
thing that really
made me feel so passionate about it was
that my
own housemaid in nigeria
came to me and said that she was
pregnant
she was 17 and i said well go home to
your parents i'm sure they will
understand and she went home to her
parents
and she came back to enugu
and started to bleed and from the mouth
i drove her down to the the hospital
got back home and i got a telephone call
and she was dead
and it was so so devastating
[Music]
the government's considering data from
50 000 telemedical abortions
as well as views from a public
consultation on whether
they should be made permanent i think
the trauma that i've suffered which i'm
also shocked about that it's classified
as ptsd
has been brought on by the fact i was
alone at home and how unprepared i was
for what i was going to have to go
through
[Music]
it's left me feeling empty i'm grief
stricken but it's a grief that i
i can't explain
i don't think i would have felt
comfortable experiencing pain like that
in a different environment i think it
felt so nice
to be at home so i didn't feel
embarrassed i could just take care of
myself
i think i would feel more unsafe if the
pills by post service wasn't available
because it was such a safe and simple
experience for me